Die 2. Liga der Männer, sie war zumindest für ein Wochenende der Zuschauer eine Magnet des deutschen Fußballs. Seit dieser Saison neu dabei, die SV Elversberg. Außerdem steht Eintracht Braunschweig trotz einer Niederlage weiterhin über dem Strich. Kaiserslautern holt den ersten Punkt unter dem neuen Trainer Friedhelm Funkel. Darüber rede ich mit Anna, Jonas und Moritz. Viel Spaß!
Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, seit der letzten Sendung zur 2. Liga vor knapp drei Wochen ist ziemlich viel in dieser Liga passiert. Man könnte fast täglich oder zumindest wöchentlich über diese Liga sprechen. Man könnte fast sagen, Max hat es auch mit dem Sendungstitel bei der letzten Folge vielleicht ein bisschen gejinkst oder zumindest die Zukunft von Tim Walter beim HSV. Aber um den soll es tatsächlich heute nicht gehen, sondern um ein paar andere Vereine in dieser Liga. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich sowohl das Debüt des Teams als auch eines Gastes hier heute anmoderieren darf. Hallo Jonas, schön, dass du dabei bist. Und die wichtigste Frage zuerst, wie gefällt es dir denn in Liga 2?
Ja, bis jetzt ist es wie ein Schlaraffenland für uns. Also vor zweieinhalb Jahren noch irgendwie Regionaliga gekickt und der Traum war dritte Liga und jetzt stehen wir irgendwo im grauen Mittelfeld der zweiten Liga und es könnte nicht schöner sein.
Sie ist auf jeden Fall ein wenig gastfreundlich, diese Liga. Ja, und bei dir und Daniel Scherning muss ich mich vollumfänglich entschuldigen, Anna. Denn ich habe zum Hinrundenende gesagt, dass ich der festen Überzeugung bin, dass Eintracht Braunschweig abgestiegen ist, dass Daniel Scherning keinen Trainerinfekt mit sich bringt. Und wie sieht deine Gemütslage nach, zumindest neun Punkten in der Rückrunde und Platz drei der Rückrunden-Tabelle aus?
Es keimt Optimismus und damit geht es mir besser, als ich bei meinem letzten Besuch hier je zu träumen gewagt hätte. Insofern ganz gut.
Ja und auch mit dabei in dieser Runde ist Moritz Kreilinger. Ihm geht es wahrscheinlich am schlechtesten momentan. Ich freue mich trotzdem, dass du uns den Trainerwechsel in Kaiserslautern ein bisschen erklärst. Du hast dich uns selbst mit den Worten irgendwie bei uns vorgestellt. Ich bin immer dabei, wenn der FCK kurz vor einem Abstieg von einer Insolvenz steht. Also schön, dass du dabei bist. Wie schlimm ist es?
Ich freue mich auch dabei zu sein. Insolvenz droht nicht. Und ich glaube, dass auch kein Abstieg droht, weil Friedhelm Funkel, wenn Friedhelm Funkel es nicht schafft, diese Mannschaft zu retten, dann hätte es vermutlich niemand geschafft.
Ja, wir starten rein mit den Hot Takes und da möchte ich euch direkt noch eine Anschlussfrage stellen, weil natürlich widmen wir uns gleich euren drei Teams, aber trotzdem, damit uns niemand vorwerfen kann, dass wir nicht am Puls der Zeit, was diese Liga betrifft, sind. Steigt der HSV denn jetzt mit Steffen Baumgart endlich auf, Anna?
Nein, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, es ist eine gute Wahl, weil er weiß, wie man auf bockenden Pferden sitzt, ohne dass ihn das, glaube ich, weiter belastet und ich glaube, dass das dem HSV gerade deshalb gut tun wird, weil sie nicht aufsteigen werden und deshalb jemanden brauchen, der in diesen unruhigen Fahrwassern, die da dann bevorstehen, irgendwie die Orientierung behält.
Ja, dass er aufsteigen kann, hat er in Paderborn gezeigt, dass er Traditionsvereine mit einer großen Wucht beherrschen kann, das hat er in Köln gezeigt. Also ist er zumindest auf dem Papier der prädestinierte Mann jetzt für den HSV. Und ich glaube, dass es auch jetzt gerade nach den vielen gescheiterten Anläufen mit Tim Walther einfach diesen neuen Impuls gebraucht hat. Und ich glaube, er führt sie in die Relegation und dort geht es dann gegen den 1. Na klar.
Ja, also ich bin ein bisschen zwielgespalten. Ich denke, dass sie den Aufstieg schaffen werden, weil ich auch – also ich habe so ein kleines Herz noch für St. Pauli und hoffe einfach, dass es nächstes Jahr ein schönes Derby in der 1. Liga gibt. Ich finde den Wechsel aber so gesehen relativ doof, weil wir jetzt am nächsten Samstag gegen HFV spielen und die werden wahrscheinlich bis unter das Dach motiviert sein, um da irgendwie drei Punkte zu Hause einzufahren. Und deswegen gefällt mir der Wechsel auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so gut.
Aber dann starten wir doch direkt tatsächlich mal rein mit deiner SVE. Dass du wahrscheinlich der Erste bist in der Runde, wenn man in die – von der Tabelle guckt, hättest du wahrscheinlich auch Anfang der Saison nicht gedacht. Man steht auf Platz 9, nach dem 22. Spieltag 32 Punkte, 10 Punkte Abstand auf einen direkten Abstandsplatz und 20 Punkte mehr als Mitaussteiger Frauvel Osnabrück. Magst du uns einfach mal so ein bisschen aufzeigen? Du hast gesagt, du bist seit 12 Jahren Fan der SVE. Wie bist du zu dem Verein gekommen und wie siehst du Elversberg?
Ja, also, wie bin ich zu dem Verein gekommen? Das ist eigentlich wahrscheinlich wie bei den anderen aus. Auch irgendwie sucht sich der Verein einen selber aus. Also ich habe irgendwann spät abends sehr kalt, sehr verregnet bei einem Spiel gegen den FC Homburg da im Stadion gestanden. Und seitdem gehe ich eigentlich immer wieder hin. Irgendwas lässt mich an dem Verein irgendwie nicht los. Und mich zieht es auch immer wieder nach Elversberg an die Kaiserlinde. Und es ist einfach jeden Samstag mit Freunden einfach Fußball gucken. Und deswegen ist es einfach schön. Und die Entwicklungen in den letzten Jahren, ja, es ist einfach irre. Man hat gehofft, dass man nach dem Aufstieg in die dritte Liga sich da irgendwie etablieren kann, dass man dann so dadurch marschiert. Das war uns allen irgendwie – also wir haben uns selbst irgendwie am 27. Spieltag haben wir uns immer noch die Augen gerieben, obwohl da so eine Schwächephase dann langsam losgetreten wurde. Aber es ist schon irre, auch wenn man sieht, klar, es ist ein Investor, ein Geldgeber hinten dran, aber mit dem Geld wurde auch richtig gut gewirtschaftet. Also die Mannschaft und das Team zwischen Ole Bog und Horst Steffen, das passt einfach total gut.
Ja, Horst Steffen ist jetzt seit fünfeinhalb Jahren, glaube ich, Trainer, wenn ich das richtig recherchiert habe. Davor waren seine Trainerstationen tatsächlich ja immer eher so auf maximal zwei Jahre begrenzt. Was hat er geschafft und warum ist er vielleicht auch so lange geblieben, hat er auch gesagt. Ich bleibe über ein paar Jahre in der Regionalliga Südwest hinaus da und das dann im Prinzip am Ende auch der Drittliga und der Zweite-Liga-Ausstieg stand.
Also ich glaube, das hat so ein bisschen auch, das hängt auf jeden Fall zusammen mit Ole Bog und so ein bisschen der Veränderung der Philosophie, die man bei Elversberg gemerkt hat. Also vorher hatte man gerade auch bei dem Drittliga-Ausstieg, man hat Spieler mit Namen geholt, die dem Verein irgendwo weitergeholfen haben, wie zum Beispiel Edmund Kaplani oder Milan Ivana. Die haben dann aber nicht dieses Steigerungspotenzial mehr gehabt. Also man hat Spieler gekauft und sich irgendwo ablösefrei besorgt. Man wusste, was man bekommt, aber da war kein Steigerungspotenzial mehr da. Und Ole Bog hat so ein bisschen angefangen auch Leute zu holen, wo jetzt nicht der große Name dahinter war, aber wo auf jeden Fall noch Steigerungspotenzial da war. Und das sieht man jetzt zum Beispiel an Robin Fellauer, an Janik Rochelt, jetzt auch wieder total krasser Transfer eigentlich Paul Stock aus der Regionalliga geholt in die 2. Liga und es funktioniert irgendwie. Also da wurde jetzt nicht mehr so auf die riesigen Namen gesetzt. Die riesigen Namen Volte, Made oder Wanner, die werden jetzt eher ausgeliehen. Aber ansonsten hat sich auch so ein bisschen was gedreht an der Philosophie. Deswegen dieser Umschwung von Horst Steffen und Uwe Buk zusammen von vorherigen Trainern wie Michael Wiesinger oder so, das passt einfach dann.
Ja, du hast gerade schon so ein bisschen den Kader angesprochen. Es fällt ja schon auf, dass es tatsächlich auch ein guter Mix ist zwischen Spielern, die eben seit den Regionalliga-Zeiten beim Verein sind und die jetzt auch erst in Liga 2 dazu gestoßen sind. Du hast auch schon gesagt, ein paar Laigeschäfte. Wie wichtig ist es da auch irgendwie einen Kern aufzubauen, der auch über diese Saison hinweg bleibt beim Verein?
Also das war in den letzten Jahren und wird jetzt noch viel wichtiger, weil man eben auch sieht, wie wichtig Personalien, wie zum Beispiel Janik Rochelt oder auch der Tochter, Nikolas Christoph, wie wichtig die eben für die Entwicklung waren, weil sie eben in Elversberg in medialer Vollstille ihr Entwicklungspotenzial ausschöpfen können und sich da auch richtig entwickeln können. Also da ist es dann auch sehr wichtig, dass man so so jungen Spielern dann die Chance gibt und sie auch behält und vorher war eher größere Fluktuation da, dann ging mal im Sommer 13 Spieler, dann kamen 11 neue und weg von diesem Trend hat man es jetzt geschafft wirklich einen Kern aufzubauen, mit dem man dann auch mit den Leichspielern außenrum einen guten Kader dann auch stellen kann.
Ja, man lasst tatsächlich mal reingehen, so ein bisschen in die Saison. Magst du mal so ein bisschen erklären, was ist so die Spielweise von Herrn Steffen und wie hat er es auch geschafft? Also ich glaube, es gab ja nur so zwei oder maximal drei wirklich hohe Niederlagen bisher. Wie lässt er am liebsten spielen und wie flexibel ist denn auch seine Spielweise?
Also da ist eigentlich das Lustige daran, dass er eigentlich relativ gerne mit Viererkette spielen lässt. Hat aber dann in der letzten Saison zum Beispiel, als es gegen 1860 München ging, wo die noch wirklich vorne dabei waren, hat er einfach mal auf eine Dreierkette umgestellt und dadurch wurde im Grunde genommen die erste Halbzeit gewonnen. 1860 war völlig überrascht. Und so kann man das im Grunde genommen auf die letzten zwei Jahre um München, also der hat zwar ein festes Spielsystem mit 4-4-2 am liebsten, aber – und das ist echt immer krass zu sehen – so Umstellungen oder immer hier am Anfang der Saison hat Tore Jacobsen total gut performt, neben Simi Sahin war immer dafür zuständig, die Bälle im Grunde genommen zu verteilen, Simi Sahin ging dann immer in die Tiefe mit viel Tempo, dann hat sich Tore Jacobsen ein paar Aussetzer geleistet, der wurde dann ausgetauscht, der etatmäßige rechtsaußen Verteidiger Robin Fellauer ging dann auf die 6er-Position und irgendwie hat es funktioniert. Also das ist jetzt auch wieder mit den Innenverteidigern, das Krasse ist eigentlich in Elversberg, es wird irgendwie ausgebügelt und alles funktioniert irgendwie in den letzten zwei Jahren. Also jetzt auch mit der Innenverteidigung, man hat vor der Saison Frederik Jekyll besorgt von RB Leipzig, damit man irgendjemanden hat, der über 1, 90 ist. Dann wird er gesperrt, man holt in der allerletzten Minute der Transferperiode jemanden von Molenbeek, Florian Lejeancourt, der auch über 1, 90 ist, damit man wieder die Größe in drin hat. Der spielt das erste Spiel, als hätte er irgendwie eine komplette Vorbereitung mitgemacht. Frederik Jekyll bekommt einen Kreuzbandrist und Lejeancourt macht im Grunde genommen da einfach weiter, wo er angefangen hat. Also alles funktioniert irgendwie. Das ist total irre und das macht es dann auch, glaube ich, Horst Steffen, das hat auch schon mehrfach gesagt, relativ einfach, weil er einfach das Gefühl hat, dass alles irgendwie im Kollektiv aufgefangen wird in Elversberg.
Ja, das fand ich tatsächlich sehr interessant jetzt beim Spiel gegen Osnabrück. Also da hatte ich schon so das Gefühl, klar kam da auch immer die Druckphase von Osnabrück, aber es war einfach ein sehr solides Konstrukt, trotz auch irgendwie vier neuen Spielern, auch irgendwie so einem neuen Innenverteidiger-Dur auf jeden Fall für die Partie, weil eben Frederik Jekyll – ich kenne ihn tatsächlich, weil er auch letzte Saison bei Minier Bielefeld noch gespielt hat als Innenverteidiger. Aber ich bin tatsächlich, ich hatte es so nicht erwartet, weil ich muss gestehen, ich dachte, ich hatte sie so ein bisschen in die Kategorie, ja wie früher vielleicht, wie in Wiesbaden oder auch so, also die Kategorie, so ein bisschen auf jeden Fall hohe, ja doch zu hoher Unterschied, gerade wenn man halt so durchmarschiert. Wenn du jetzt so auf die Saison guckst, was war da für dich so der Moment, wo du dachtest, okay, vielleicht müssen wir gar nicht so sehr nach unten gucken.
Also der Moment, wo man gemerkt hat, okay, die Mannschaft, die lässt sich hier nicht nur abschießen, war eigentlich im Grunde genommen dieses 1 zu 0 in Osnabrück nach dem 5 zu 0 gegen Düsseldorf in der Vorrunde, weil man da eben gemerkt hat, okay, der Trainer und die Mannschaft, auch wenn die mal 5 zu 0 verlieren, die lassen sich jetzt nicht irgendwie unterkriegen oder verändern die Spielweise, sondern die vertrauen auch ihr Spiel, haben dann auch in Osnabrück gewonnen und dann den Dreier danach gegen Hamburg geholt. Also da hat man wirklich gemerkt, in diesen drei Spielen wurde einem dann wirklich klar, okay, wenn hier dieser Geist von diesem, wir bleiben zusammen und spielen unser Spiel, wenn der erhalten bleibt, dann hat man tatsächlich eine reelle Chance, irgendwie in der Liga zu bleiben.
Ja, ich möchte tatsächlich einmal die anderen beiden da so ein bisschen mit reinholen. Anna, hattest du die SVE irgendwie so auf dem Zettel? Also wusstest du so, was kommt mit euch? Natürlich ja, also so ein bisschen was konkurriert da mit euch vielleicht auch möglicherweise um den Klassenerhalt?
Nicht wirklich, muss ich zugeben. Ich hatte das erste Spiel verfolgt, das ja auswärts hier in Hannover stattgefunden hat und bin mir selbst da so ein bisschen auf die Schliche gekommen, wie wenig ich tatsächlich das Transfergeschehen auf den anderen Plätzen mitbekommen hatte, weil ja ein ehemaliger Braunschweger, Marcel Correia, da dann in der Stadteif stand und das hat mich tatsächlich dann irgendwie wirklich neugierig gemacht, weil ich weiß, dass der Junge technisch sehr, sehr auffällig ist für uns, auch wirklich auf hohem Niveau gespielt hat, halt sehr anfällig war für Verletzungen, immer wieder irgendwie mit Knie zu kämpfen hatte. Na dann dachte er, okay, das ist also irgendwie aufschlussreich in Bezug auf eine gewisse Transferphilosophie. Mit wem versucht man es, wer hat irgendwie gut funktioniert, braucht vielleicht ein bisschen Glück oder Geduld oder mit wem – ja, Pokern wir so ein bisschen haben, sehr guten Spieler, wenn er fit bleibt. Und hab mich dann tatsächlich erst nach Ankunft in der Liga von der SV Elversberg so ein bisschen mit dem Verein auseinandergesetzt, vorher tatsächlich nicht nur sich zugeben.
Auf jeden Fall in den vergangenen Jahren immer mal wieder beruflich beim 1. FC Saarbrücken. Und ja, ich hab dort auch einige Leute kennengelernt, die haben mir letztes Jahr alle sehr leid getan, weil sie sind so oft jetzt in den letzten Jahren knapp an diesem Aufstieg zurück in die 2. Liga gescheitert. Und ja, dann kommt Elversberg und marschiert einfach einmal durch diese Liga durch. Und Saarbrücken hängt weiter da unten drin. Aber zurück zu Elversberg. Es ist ja häufig so, dass Mannschaften, die in so einem Flow drin sind, die sogar jetzt einfach mal durch die 3. Liga durchmarschiert sind. Und wenn du diesen Flow einfach mitnehmen kannst und wenn das Mannschaftsgefühl gepasst und wenn du es schaffst, wie der Jonas jetzt erklärt hat, es auf einzelnen Positionen gezielt zu ergänzen, dass es dann gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich ist, dass du einfach auch in der 2. Liga eine sehr solide, eine sehr gute Rolle spielst und zumindest nicht vom ersten bis zum letzten Tag mit den Abstiegssorgen zu tun hast. Deswegen wundert es mich nicht, dass die SV Elversberg diese Rolle spielt, die sie spielt.
Ja, gerade auch in der 2. Liga, in der solche Faktoren einfach wirklich auch trumpfen. Also in der Bundesliga ist es, glaube ich, so, dass nach hinten raus individuelle Qualität nicht immer, aber sehr oft dann doch das Spiel entscheidet und entscheiden kann. Das sieht man ja auch in den direkten Vergleichen, dann 2. Liga, 1. Liga in den Relegationsspielen. Selbst wenn der 2. Ligist irgendwie tapfer ist und geschlossen auftritt und halt keine Krisensaison hinter sich hat, so wie der Bundesligist, hat der am Ende trotzdem oft irgendwie die Nase vorn. Und ich glaube, dass die 2. Liga über diese Werte tatsächlich gut funktioniert und du ja fast auch darauf spekulieren kannst, dass wenn du ein Team hast, das funktioniert, dass du gegen Teams antrittst, die nicht nur nicht funktionieren, sondern deshalb auch einfach ihre Qualität nicht auf den Platz bringen können, wie es jetzt bei Schalke 04 relativ häufig der Fall ist. Die halt individuell besser besetzt sind, aber mit Stimmungsproblemen kriegst du einfach wirklich da mitunter keinen Fuß auf dem Boden. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert. Insofern ist das absolut plausibel.
Es ist auch krass, wenn man es jetzt mal runterbrechen will. Also Elversberg ist ja, oder wir sind ja in die Liga gestartet, im Grunde genommen mit 9 Millionen Marktwert, wenn man es mal plakativ machen will. Davon gehen 3, 5 Millionen auf die Kappe von Paul Wanner. Also und jetzt mittlerweile steht Elversberg, glaube ich, bei 18. 18, 5 Millionen Marktwert und davon gehen 6 Millionen auf die Kappe von Paul Wanner und Wahid Fargir. Also das sind zwei Spieler, die ein Drittel von diesem kompletten Marktwert ausmachen. Das bestätigt ja im Grunde genommen schon so ein bisschen das, was ihr auch sagt. Also es geht schon über dieses Gefüge und dieses mannschaftliche Zusammenstehen dann auch.
Ich finde, die Anna hat eben was ganz wichtiges gesagt, dass speziell die 2. Liga sehr empfänglich dafür ist, mit so einem geschlossenen Mannschaftsgefüge dort Erfolg haben zu können. Weil wir sehen es ja ganz genauso auch andersrum. Wie viele Bundesligisten haben dann in den letzten Jahren wirklich im ersten Jahr nach dem Abstieg oder es heißt zumindest mal nur ein halbes Jahr, in diesem Negative Flow extreme Probleme gehabt? Und unter Umständen rutscht Schalke ja jetzt wirklich komplett unten durch.
Ich kann da auch Geschichten von erzählen. Das ist vielleicht nicht der, den man als klassischen etablierten Bundesligisten sieht, aber On the verge of Regionalliga ist auf jeden Fall ein spaßiges Thema. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Sorge bezeichnen kann, aber was natürlich so ein bisschen ist, dadurch, dass man eben von der Regionalliga Südwest in die 2. Liga durchmarschiert ist, fehlt natürlich so ein bisschen die Konstanz, mal ein paar Jahre in der 3. Liga gespielt zu haben, um sich dann vielleicht ein paar Jahre in der 2. Liga zu fangen. Also es ist dann natürlich schon ein Schritt. Klar, den kann man auch gut auffangen. Ich glaube, auch gerade so etwas wie der FC Heidenheim ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ein Vorbild, könnte man ja fast sagen. Also einfach was sowas betrifft. Glaubst du denn, dass da auch die richtigen Entscheidungen schon jetzt, also dass man vielleicht so ein bisschen auch glücklicherweise in der Lage ist, vielleicht besser schon mit einem halben Auge auf die nächste Saison zu bleiben? Also in dieser Liga ist alles möglich. Aber es ist natürlich doch, dass man so eine gewisse Planungssicherheit vielleicht schon von Spieltag zu Spieltag entwickelt und dann bestimmt sicherlich auch mit jemandem, also mit einer Idee, die es Horst Steffen hat und mit der Erfahrung, die er schon bei der SV Elversberg hat, sicherlich auch einen Attraktiv wird für zukünftige Transfers.
Ja, also bei 32 Punkten momentan, ich glaube, wenn da kein Punkt mehr dazu kommt, dann kann man eher für die 3. Liga planen, aber es wird von 3er zu 3er wahrscheinlicher und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die Vertragsgespräche natürlich hinten dran aussehen, aber ich denke schon, dass man da versuchen wird, auch wie in den letzten Jahren, wieder dieses große Gerüst zu halten, um sich dann wieder gezielt mit Laien zu verstärken. Der Verein an sich entwickelt sich auf jeden Fall immer weiter. Also ich habe mir irgendwann mal angewöhnt, immer im Stadion so ein Stadionheft mitzunehmen. Da habe ich jetzt am Wochenende mal verglichen, vor genau zehn Jahren, also im ersten drittliger Jahr von Elversberg, haben sie auch gegen Osnabrück gespielt. Da hat die SV Elversberg 41 Sponsoren ausgewiesen. Jetzt am Wochenende waren es 237, glaube ich. Also der Verein wächst überall, das Stadion wächst und man sieht sich da schon, das hat man vor einigen Jahren auch formuliert, man sieht sich schon eher in der zweiten Liga, dritte Liga, also das ist schon das Ziel, wo man eigentlich hin will. Man ist jetzt halt ein bisschen sehr schnell dahin gekommen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall so den Bereich, wo man sich selber irgendwo sehen möchte und deswegen, ich glaube schon, dass da irgendwas in den Schubladen lag dafür, aber das musste jetzt halt eben super schnell rausgeholt werden und inwiefern das jetzt für die Zukunft dann noch Sicherheit gibt bzw. was von den Plänen, die damals gemacht wurden, jetzt noch übertragbar ist, weil es ja eben neuer Trainer, neuer Sportdirektor und alles ein bisschen umgestellt, was man dafür jetzt noch verwenden kann, das ist natürlich immer die Frage.
Ja, ich finde es auf jeden Fall super interessant, weil ich muss auch gestehen, ich hatte sie jetzt bis zum Mitte der letzten Saison nicht so richtig auf dem Zettel.
Ja, nennen wir einen, der die auf dem Zettel hat.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch immer ein Vorteil. Also, Anna hat es eben auch angesprochen. Anna hat ja eben angesprochen, auf den Vorteil, wirklich auch in Ruhe arbeiten zu können. Also, dass eben, wenn es am Ende dann, weiß ich nicht, Platz 12 wird oder 14, oder es vielleicht hinten raus doch noch ein bisschen knapper wird, da kommt ja keine Unruhe auf. Aber man kann eben auch mehr in Ruhe arbeiten. Also, ich meine, ich erinnere an auch vielleicht Kaiserslautern in der letzten Saison, die auch als Aussteiger relativ gut reingestiegen sind. Und zum Ende hin wurde es dann halt damals auch schon etwas ungemütlicher, weil die Ergebnisse auch ausgeblieben sind etc. Und ich meine, wir sprechen nachher noch über den FCK, Moritz freut sich schon. Aber ich glaube, man spricht ja ganz oft von Standortvorteilen etc. und meint damit vielleicht sowas wie Wirtschaftslage und Sponsorenhaltkräftigkeit. Aber ich glaube, gerade jetzt, wenn wir eben sehen, welche Vereine haben denn Probleme, in der Liga zu bleiben oder haben immer wieder Probleme, auch ihren eigenen Anforderungen zu folgen, da ist es auch einfach ein Vorteil, wenn eben nicht vielleicht in dem Sinne halt Deutschland draufguckt und erwartet, dass man Scheid hat, so nach dem Motto, sondern sagt so, ach, wir sind einfach positiv überrascht, wenn es klappt. Und ich glaube, da kann man also gerade eben, weil man auch einen Trainer hat, der auch schon länger im Verein ist und der da auch, ja, zumindest in der Regionalliga auch lange Zeit hatte, sich zu überlegen, was ist sein Plan. Das kann auf jeden Fall gut werden. Was ist denn so dein Wunsch, wie Elversberg denn jetzt auch die nächsten Spiele beschreitet, beziehungsweise denkst du, da wird sich vielleicht auch noch mal der ein oder andere größere Verein von oben doch noch mal umblicken müssen?
Also ich glaube, am nächsten Samstag gegen HSV, das wird schon extrem schwer. Aber wir haben auch am Sonntag im Stadion gestanden und haben gesagt, okay, also wenn man die Spiele, die man jetzt in Anführungsstrichen noch gewinnen muss, wenn man die gewinnt, also gegen Wiesbaden, gegen Magdeburg, dann sollte es am Schluss reichen. Und dann ist das anderes, dann ob man dann, weiß ich nicht, Hamburg vielleicht doch noch irgendwie einen Punkt abluxen kann im Volksparkstadion und so. Das ist dann auch in Anführungsstrichen egal, weil, wie gesagt, wir stehen im grauen Mittelfeld, das sind 10 Punkte nach unten und 6 Punkte nach oben zum HSV. Wir sind neunter und es ist einfach das Geilste. Also es ist einfach, keine Ahnung, solange wir nicht weiter runter rutschen, da wird sich auch nichts verändern und das war auch schon zu Anfang der Saison so, als wir im Stadion standen und haben diese 0-5-Klatsche gegen Düsseldorf erleiden müssen, dann sind wir irgendwie aus dem Stadion raus und haben gesagt, ja, es ist trotzdem geil, es ist halt 2. Liga. Also insofern, klar, die Liga halten wäre natürlich das Ziel und wenn man sich mit seiner Spielweise, die wirklich gut zur Mannschaft passt, wenn man da noch die entscheidenden Punkte holen kann, dann denke ich, steht einem nächsten Jahr in der 2. Liga nichts im Weg.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessante Punkte. Ich bin tatsächlich sehr gespannt, wie das läuft. Ich glaube, da sind viele richtige Zeichen schon auch über die Saison hinweg erkannt worden und man musste sich eben schon mit viel auseinandersetzen, was du alles angesprochen hast, verletzungsbedingt. Da schauen, dass man das vernünftig gestemmt bekommt und ich glaube, da ist man wahrscheinlich auch schon einen Schritt weiter als vielleicht andere Aufsteiger und man bringt halt so eine gewisse Flexibilität mit, die einem auch immer viel nutzen kann in der 2. Liga. Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, wir schauen einmal ein Verein weiter und wir schauen auf Platz 15 und Eintracht Braunschweig, 23 Punkte. Es ist noch immer die zweitschlechteste Offensive, aber seit Daniel Scherning am 13. Spieltag übernommen hat, 6 Siege, 4 Niederlagen, keine Unentschieden und vor allem zwischenzeitlich die Siegesserie in 2024 von 4 Siegen in Folge Wiesbaden, Lautern, Kiel, Magdeburg und ja, wahrscheinlich nur die Niederlage gegen Schalke, schmerzhaft. Anna, was hat sich denn unter Scherning getan?
Ich freue mich, wie du dich freust. Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich würde gerne, wenn das in Ordnung ist, noch ein Mühe früher ansetzen. Und zwar haben sich relativ viele Dinge bei uns geändert im Verein. Peter Vollmann hatte letzten Sommer Jens Hettel installiert als Trainer und Nachfolger von Michael Schiele, was nicht so richtig nachvollziehbar war für die meisten im Umfeld, sich dann auch als Fehler rausgestellt hat, weil wir einfach katastrophal gespielt haben und entsprechend katastrophale Ergebnisse erzielt haben. Und wir waren alle schon komplett hoffnungslos, also nicht alle, ich schon, wie auch immer, weil einfach nichts Hoffnung gegeben hat im Verein, nichts in der Mannschaft, es war alles irgendwie trostlos und grau. Und dann kam Benjamin Kessel, der lange für uns gespielt hat, auch schon länger im Verein aktiv ist, immer so als Person, die von Peter Vollmann angelernt wird, für die Rolle des Sportdirektors vorgestellt wurde. Und ich mich dann immer gefragt, ich mag den wirklich gerne, aber wie soll das denn funktionieren, wenn man vom Lehrer nicht besonders viel hält, dann in den Schülervertrauen zu haben. Und dann ist das aber tatsächlich so gekommen, also zu meines Jens Härtel entlassen worden, dann war über mehrere Wochen, in denen, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Gespräche geführt worden sind im Hintergrund, Peter Vollmann war noch im Amt, ist da dann aber diesem enthoben worden. Benni Kessel ist als sportlicher Leiter installiert worden, was ein irgendwie romantischer Akt gewesen ist und derlei romantische Aktionen fanden in Braunschweig so viel statt zuletzt, dass ich wirklich keine Romantik mehr gebraucht habe, einerseits, andererseits habe ich mich trotzdem irgendwie gefreut, weil ich den cool finde. Und man will ja auch dran glauben. Du willst ja dieser hoffnungsvolle, naive Opportunist sein. Und Benni Kessel hat dann zwei Personalentscheidungen getroffen, die – wahrscheinlich nicht alleine, aber ich beschreibe ihm das jetzt einfach mal zu – die meiner Meinung nach entscheidend sind und die Grundlage dafür, dass danach vieles besser wurde. Das war zum einen, Armin Vicacic zu holen, der lange in Hoffenheim gespielt hat, da Innenverteidiger gewesen ist, der war vertrags- und vereinslos, weil so latent verletzungsanfällig und irgendwie halt auch schon so ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen, aber ein überragender Typ, stark leistungsbezogenen Vertrag bekommen und direkt gespielt und auch direkt überzeugt. Und das in Kombination mit Daniel Scherning, ja, was hat er gemacht? Ja, also sportlich würde ich sagen, er hat Spiele auf die Positionen gesetzt, auf denen sie spielen. Und hat tatsächlich die Mannschaft, finde ich, rhetorisch irgendwie entlastet. Also ich finde den nicht, ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt nicht mein liebster Typ so im Fußballgeschäft. Ich finde den irgendwie spröde und nicht so richtig zugänglich oder sympathisch. Habe aber auch im Moment gar nicht den Anspruch an eine krasse Identifikationsfigur, weil Benni Kessel das halt total super ausfüllt und Mark Fitzner als auch Vereinslegende da irgendwie genug rumwühlt, damit dieses Bedürfnis für mich als Fan erfüllt ist und ich das nicht vom Trainer verlange. Und der halt sagt, das und das funktioniert bei uns schon gut, das und das funktioniert bei uns noch nicht so gut. Und finde ich damit ein ziemlich souveränes Erwartungsmanagement in einem nicht immer einfachen Umfeld hinbekommt. Und dann ja vielleicht sowas wie Basics, also diese unfassbare Anfälligkeit bei gegnerischen Standards ein bisschen in den Griff bekommen hat, alleine dadurch, dass er die Anzahl an Ecken im Spiel reduziert hat, die der Gegner bekommt. Und dann zu sagen, wir haben Ermin dahinten, wir zementieren da eine souveräne Defensive, nicht im Sinne von stellen wir uns hinten rein, weil das hast du mit so einer Qualität auf der Position nicht nötig, sondern wir lösen viel spielerisch nach hinten raus. Durch die Installation von Ermin sind die anderen Innenverteidiger souveräner geworden, sicherer geworden, besser geworden. Und dann das, was Mannschaften machen, wenn sie nicht so richtig gut Fußball spielen können, den anderen Leuten den Ball überlassen und fahren kann.
Ja, ich finde es tatsächlich ganz interessant, weil man sagt ja gerade im Abstiegskampf, bevor man irgendwie guckt, ob man die, ob man oben die Teams ärgert, ist halt viel wichtiger, die Siege gegen die direkten Konkurrenten zu holen. Ich würde halt sagen, eben durch die Siege gegen Wiesbaden, Lautern, Magdeburg ist das auf jeden Fall schon mal geschehen. Wie gesagt, die Niederlage gegen Schalke ist wahrscheinlich wirklich die, die dann da so ein bisschen aus dem Rahmen fällt. Aber ich muss halt echt sagen, also, wie gesagt, ich habe am Anfang schon gesagt, ich muss mich entschuldigen, weil ich zum Ende des letzten Jahres gesagt habe, ja, das funktioniert jetzt gerade unter Scherning, aber ich habe bei ihm immer das Gefühl, dass Mannschaften sich nicht weiterentwickeln. Also, dass es irgendwann der Punkt kommt, wo ja, ein Effekt, den es vielleicht auch gab, den möchte ich ihm auch überhaupt nicht irgendwie wegreden, weil den hat er in Bielefeld auch, aber dass irgendwann der Punkt kommt, wo ja dann irgendwie nicht weitergearbeitet wird. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, dafür, dass in der Winterpause ja offensiv gar nicht mal was so richtig getan wurde. Ich glaube, da hat man ja nur eine Defensive mit Anderson Lukoki, Niklas Tauer und Hampus Vindell, was übrigens ein fantastischer Name ist. Hat man ja eher in der Defensive beziehungsweise der defensives Mittelfeld, zentrales Mittelfeld nachgelegt. Und ja, man gewinnt seine Spiele meistens nur mit einem Torunterschied. Aber reicht ja am Ende. Also reicht nicht im Sinne von Torverhältnis. Das hat man sich ja leider so ein bisschen in der Innenrunde, glaube ich, schon ruiniert. Also wenn es da punktetechnisch eng werden könnte, dann guckt man wahrscheinlich da drauf. Aber ich glaube, also ich bin wirklich überrascht, wie gut er es geschafft hat, die Defensive zu stabilisieren. Und ich glaube, das ist auch mit seiner Dreierkette, die er da spielt, da hat er sich einen guten Plan gemacht. Und ja, es sind vielleicht nicht die Offensivs-Spektakel, aber so viel mehr du offensiv gehst mit einer Mannschaft, die das vielleicht gar nicht spielen möchte, desto mehr machst du hinten natürlich auch auf. Trotzdem müssen wir, glaube ich, trotzdem einmal kurz über die Offensive reden, weil es gibt dann ja doch Spiele, ich muss leider immer wieder auf dieses Schalke-Spiel zurückkommen, wo man sagt, okay, vielleicht hätte er doch vorne einer gefohlen. Also man hat ja mit Ryan Philipp oder wie immer man ihn aussprechen mag, einen, der ja in drei Spielen, in drei aufeinander folgenden Spielen drei Tore erzielt hat, aber der beste Torschütze ist Fabio Kaufmann mit nur fünf Toren. Findest du es da ein bisschen schwierig, dass man in der Winterpause nicht nachgelegt hat? Oder ist da was gescheitert etc.?
Das ist, finde ich, eine total komplizierte Frage, weil Ryan Philipp im Sommer kam und dann aber nicht gespielt hat. Und zwar gar nicht. Also der war über Wochen nicht mal im Kader und alle haben sich gefragt, was ist denn mit dem? Ist der krank? Geht es ihm nicht gut? Will der nicht? Will die Härtel nicht? Man weiß das ja nicht, keine Ahnung. Und dann war der Trainerwechsel und dann hat er immer noch nicht gespielt. Und irgendwann tauchte er dann auf und alle waren sofort total angefixt. Weil der hat so was Wildes irgendwie und ist nicht besonders geordnet, aber nicht im Sinne von irgendwie will oder desorientiert oder so, sondern so was Wuchtiges, ohne dass er eigentlich den Körper dafür hat. Und das finde ich total gefährlich. Also jetzt auch gegen Pauli, auch wenn er nicht trifft, ist er trotzdem ein total relevanter Faktor. Nicht unbedingt bei Standards, da kommen dann eher die Innenverteidiger zum Zug. Also Ermin hat jetzt drei Tore, Kurochai hat auch schon getroffen. Das funktioniert ganz gut und ist vielleicht auch in unserer Situation gar nicht das Schlechteste, wenn sich so was so ein bisschen, wenn sich wenige Tore auf viele Personen verteilen. Und wir haben, der kommt jetzt langsam wieder zurück, haben halt immer noch auch Anthony Uja im Kader. Er hat sich beim Spiel gegen Nürnberg in der Hinrunde einer schwere Schulterverletzung zugezogen, wird jetzt so langsam wieder ran geführt, wird eingewechselt, ist immer noch er selbst, aber braucht noch so ein bisschen, um die gewünschte Gefahr da wieder auch tatsächlich in Tor rumzumünzen. Wir haben mit Johann Gomes auch einen spannenden Typen, bei dem ich irgendwie mag, weil er im Gegensatz zu Philipp eher filigrane, spielerische Momente reinbringt, mal einen überraschenden Pass spielt oder einen Laufweg nimmt, bei dem er denkt, okay, was passiert und dann ist es aber am Ende cool. Deswegen finde ich uns trotz dessen, dass wir nicht so viele Tore haben, gar nicht so schlecht aufgestellt nach vorne und würde eher vermuten, dass es irgendwie für Verwirrung gesorgt hätte, wenn du den Kader jetzt noch mehr aufbläst, weil der Kader ist total groß dafür, dass wir nicht so viel Geld haben und dafür, dass wir nicht so erfolgreich sind. Da jetzt noch mehr Spieler reinzubringen, noch mehr Spieler wegzulassen, um irgendwie auf eine angestrebte Kadergröße zu kommen, hätte ich, glaube ich, nicht für klug erachtet, sondern bin da eigentlich auf der Linie, die jetzt gefahren wird, nämlich nach Möglichkeit, immer die gleiche Startelf beginnen zu lassen und den Jungs einfach Chance um Chance zu geben, da reinzuwachsen. Und das tun sie, glaube ich, schon. Man darf, glaube ich, auch nicht außer Acht lassen, in welcher Lage und in welcher Form Scherning die Mannschaft übernommen hat. Also, dass du halt, wenn jemand verhungert, dann reicht halt schon Erdnusspaste. Und ich glaube, die hatte er dabei. Ob er sich dann im Gericht etwas weiterentwickeln kann, um halt tatsächlich irgendwie für Vitalität zu sagen, das kann ich im Moment nicht einschätzen. Aber aktuell reicht's. Und ich glaube, das sieht man auch. Also, das macht schon erstaunlich viel Spaß, auch wenn die Tore leider manchmal nicht fallen, wie jetzt am Wochenende gegen St. Pauli. Halten wir trotzdem auf jeden Fall mit und haben auch mehr Ideen, als ich der Mannschaft im Oktober zugetraut hätte.
Moritz, aus der Perspektive eines FCK-Fans, hattest du das so erwartet, dass es da bei der Eintracht noch den Umschwung in der Art und Weise gibt?
Das heißt, ob ich es erwartet habe, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde aber, dieses Spiel, das der FCK am 17. Spieltag der Hinrunde gegen Braunschweig in Braunschweig hatte, das fand ich zumindest in der Hinsicht bezeichnend. Von der ersten Minute an war irgendwie der Glaube und der Wille, dieses Spiel zu gewinnen, bei Braunschweig viel offensichtlicher. Und ich weiß noch, Ragnar Acher hat ja sogar spät ein Tor geschossen, das hat dann nicht gezählt. Also mit ein bisschen Glück wäre Kaiserslautern da noch mit einem 2-2 davongekommen, aber das hatten sie ehrlich gesagt an dem Tag auch gar nicht verdient. Und es war einfach so eine Phase damals auch in Kaiserslautern, wo der Abstiegskampf irgendwie noch nicht so in den Köpfen drin war. Aber gleichzeitig hat Braunschweig den FCK damit voll unten reingezogen. Und genau so musst du im Abstiegskampf einfach auftreten. Ich hätte jetzt vielleicht nicht gedacht, dass sie wirklich so viele – ich glaube, Daniel Scherning hat einen Punkteschnitt von 1, 8. Wenn sie das so fortsetzen, dann haben sie in wenigen Wochen wahrscheinlich nichts mehr da unten mit dem Abstieg zu tun. Das werden wir dann mal sehen. Aber ja, alles richtig gemacht.
Ja, wir spielen halt nicht unentschieden. Wir haben zwei Unentschieden. Das haben wir in der gesamten Saison geholt. Wenn man stattdessen gewinnt, das ist jetzt eine richtig verrückte Erkenntnis, dann ist das gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, lass uns natürlich mal ganz kurz auf die kommenden Wochen blicken. Weil man spielt jetzt zu Hause gegen die Hertha. Hertha ist für mich eine absolute Wunderkiste momentan. Da kann irgendwie alles passieren. Vielleicht ist es da trotzdem unentschieden, vielleicht gar nicht mal so schlecht. Und dann eben auswärts in Nürnberg, zu Hause gegen Rostock. Und das wird, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich so ein, wenn man sich auf die Tabelle anguckt, schon nochmal so ein Schlüsselspiel, wenn es in den Endspurt geht. Das sollte man wahrscheinlich schon zwingend gewinnen. Danach auswärts in Paderborn. Also es ist immer so, ich habe das Gefühl, die Wochen sind dann auch immer ein bisschen abgewechselt zwischen, okay, müssen wir nicht unbedingt gewinnen, sollten wir vielleicht punkten und müssen wir auf jeden Fall gewinnen. Aber ich glaube eben der Vorteil ist, weil man zwischendurch immer wieder diese, oder dass man diesen Run drin hatte, also dass man einmal zeigen konnte, okay, wir können durchaus Konstanz aufbauen und wir lassen uns durch eine Niederlage nicht komplett aus dem Konzept bringen und in so eine Negativspirale reinrutschen. Ich habe so das Gefühl, da wurde auch einfach mental sehr, sehr viel getan, um da irgendwie die vernünftigen Worte zu finden nach Niederlagen und einfach einen vernünftigen Weg zu finden. Und ja, dann bin ich auch gerne in die Person, die zugibt, dass sie keine Ahnung hatte, was der Kerl vielleicht auch kann, gebe ich gerne zu. Aber ich finde es wirklich interessant, welche Spieler da jetzt auch funktionieren, sage ich mal. Und dass man vielleicht auch – weil du hast ja auch recht mit Anthony Uja – dass das Ganze natürlich auch schief laufen kann, wenn du dann sagst, okay, wir geben dir eigentlich die Zeit, dich zu erholen, holen aber in der Winterpause irgendwie noch irgendeinen Stürmer und viel Spaß bei der Erholung. Du spielst eh nicht mehr. Das kann natürlich auch für einen – ich weiß jetzt von außen nicht, wie wichtig ein Uja auch einfach fürs Mannschaftsgefüge ist, aber das kann sowas ja auch zerstören, wenn man dann sagt, okay, und du bist dann auch auf dem Feld raus. Weil ja, so eine Präsenz hat er ja definitiv auch auf dem Platz, dass man weiß, okay, er steht an der Seitenlinie, nimmt wahrscheinlich die Fans mit und nimmt wahrscheinlich auch die Mitspieler mit.
Ja, definitiv. Also Uja ist alle liebend, denn das ist ein Phänomen irgendwie, weil er ja jetzt nicht besonders lange bei uns war, aber absoluter Publikumsliebling. Und ich bin gespannt auch, was das an Personalentscheidungen nach sich zieht. Also lässt er Uja und Philipp zu zweit spielen, weil irgendwie fühlt sich das doppelt gemoppelt an, aber vielleicht funktioniert das auch. Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Mal schauen. Also ich glaube, man kann diese musst du gewinnen, musst du nicht gewinnen Dinge in der zweiten Liga kaum mit drei Wochen, vier Wochen Vorsprung sagen. Mal gucken, in welcher Form dann die jeweilige Mannschaft sein wird. Bei Rostock würde ich sagen, gerade zu Hause musst du, also alleine wegen Tabelle. Und dann der nächste Schritt, wenn wir uns da so etabliert haben, wenn wir eben auch besser Fußball spielen können, im Sinne von mit dem Ball Fußball spielen können. Was dann passiert und ob Scherning das kann, das vermag ich jetzt gerade nicht einzuschätzen. Aber ich finde schon, dass es spielerisch über diesen Trainer-Effekt hinausgeht, was wir in den letzten Wochen gesehen haben.
Den Trainer-Effekt, den hatte der FCK.
Ja, ich finde tatsächlich auch gerade finanziell wird es wahrscheinlich auch wirklich wichtig sein. Du hast die finanzielle Lage schon angesprochen, sich tatsächlich noch ein weiteres Jahr 2. Liga zu sichern. Das wird wahrscheinlich ja auch das Hauptaugenmerk sein. Da bin ich dann auch gespannt, was der Verein da auf die Beine stellt. Aber an sich generell zu sagen, wir planen das jetzt erst mal so und das kann klappen, ist natürlich auch einfach ein wichtiger Schritt. Weil da kommt wieder das Stichwort Konstanz, Planungssicherheit. Das ist einfach das, was zwei 2. Liga-Jahre kann dann auch richtig weh tun, wenn du dich immer in so einer Konsolidierungsphase befindest. Schwieriges Wort, ich vergesse auch einfach, ich habe auch einen Infekt an der Stelle, sich da irgendwie zu finden. Und ich glaube, da hatte Braunschweig ja auch immer mal wieder Probleme in den letzten Jahren. Und ich glaube aber, ich finde es super interessant, was du erzählst, wie viel wichtiger ist es vielleicht auf der Position außerhalb des Spielfelds nach der Romantik zu suchen oder nach eben den Personen, die da auch dem Verein viel bedeuten, als vielleicht immer so ein bisschen auf der Trainerposition zu sagen, okay, ich brauche da jetzt nicht Torsten Leverknecht 2.0, sondern es reicht einer, der uns einfach dahin bringt, wo wir hin müssen und den Rest, den Regeln der Verein.
Ja, absolut. Ja, und das Vertrauen auch wieder in den Verein zu haben und zu wissen, okay, die Leute sind da, sie kümmern sich, und zwar in einem Sinne, den ich zu einem großen Prozentsatz teile. Auch da habe ich ja nicht den Anspruch, dass das zu 100 Prozent meiner Perspektive entspricht, wenn dann das Ergebnis passt. Aber da bin ich, also diese Installation von Benni Kessel erachte ich für alles, auch die Geduld mit der Defense, die Entscheidungen dann erst mal abwarten, weil sie jemanden trifft, den sie schätzen und mögen. Auch das sind ja Faktoren, die einfach nicht irrelevant sind. Das war wirklich wichtig und gut. Darüber bin ich sehr froh.
Ja, ich würde tatsächlich einmal weitergehen wollen.
Ich verschwinde einmal kurz aus meinem Bild und installiere ein Ladegerät.
Weil, Moritz, ich glaube, das sind alles Dinge, von denen der FCK das auch irgendwie gerne wieder hätte. So ein bisschen Vertrauen. Man steht auf Platz 16, 22 Punkte. Man ist bei dem dritten Trainer dieser Saison. Man hat Gramozis entlassen, Friedhelm Funkel wurde installiert. Er hat jetzt sein erstes Spiel am Wochenende zumindest mit einem Punkt holen können. Ich habe, glaube ich, von einem Kollegen vom Kicker eine lustige Grafik gesehen, dass die neuen Trainer immer mit Nürnberg begonnen mussten. Das ist auch ein komischer Kurs. Weil ich ein Spiel schwierig finde, zu sagen, was das für einen Effekt hat. Aber nimm uns doch mal ein bisschen mit in die vergangenen Wochen beim FCK.
Ja, wo fangen wir an? Wo hören wir auf? Wie viel Zeit haben wir? Lass uns mal zurückspringen an den neunten Spieltag dieser Saison. Am neunten Spieltag dieser Saison hatte der FCK 17 Punkte und stand auf Platz 3. Und jeder hat gedacht, gut, letztes Jahr hatte die Mannschaft schon die ganze Hinrunde oben mitgespielt, ist in der Rückrunde eingebrochen. Im Sommer wurde die Mannschaft verstärkt, punktuell. Und dann war das für viele einfach der logische Schritt, dass der FCK wieder oben mitspielt. Aus der heutigen Perspektive wissen wir, dass schon damals in dieser Mannschaft vieles im Argen lag. Ich glaube aber persönlich, dass es Dirk Schuster damals geschafft hat, das so ein bisschen zu überspielen oder zumindest es zu schaffen, dass es nicht ans Tageslicht gekommen ist. Es waren dann viele unglückliche Umstände. Es war eine 3-0-Führung in Düsseldorf. Das Spiel ist noch verloren gegangen. Ragnar Ache, mit Abstand der beste Torschütze vom FCK und meiner Meinung nach mit Abstand einer der besten Stürmer in der 2. Liga in dieser Saison, hat sich verletzt, hat dann monatelang gefehlt. Ja, und dann hat eins zum anderen geführt und drei Wochen später bzw. drei Niederlagen später musste Dirk Schuster auf einmal gehen. Das waren sicherlich nicht nur diese drei Spiele ausschlaggebend, sondern auch so ein bisschen die Gesamtentwicklung, die sich der Verein anders vorgestellt hatte. Ja, aber jetzt gehen wir mal in diese Woche, in der Dirk Schuster entlassen worden ist, weil da war vieles ja kurios bis bis unsouverän, weil wer entlässt einen Trainer an einem Donnerstagmittag, rund 48 Stunden vor dem nächsten Spiel und hat dann nicht mal eine Alternative parat, sondern schickt dann ein Interims-Duo ins Rennen. Also wir wissen, der FCK hatte in dieser Woche mit vielen Trainern verhandelt. Er hat von vielen Trainern Absagen kassiert, unter anderem Enrico Maaßen, den wir ja aus Augsburg kennen. Sie wollten Michael Wimmer, der war mein Stuttgart-Co-Trainer und Interimstrainer und aktuell bei Austria Wien unter Vertrag, den wollten sie haben. Es hat alles nicht geklappt. Und dann haben sie die Geschuße trotzdem entlassen und haben dann nach diesem Interimsspiel Dimitrios Kramotsis verpflichtet. Und diese ganzen Abläufe, die legen ja nahe, dass Kramotsis nicht die Wunschlösung war. Weil, wer die gewesen wäre, war frei, dann hätte er schon eine Woche früher anfangen können. Und dadurch, dass das so offensichtlich war, hatte man ihm in Kaiserslautern noch keinen Gefallen getan, weil jeder wusste, okay, eigentlich ist es nicht der, der hier hätte herkommen sollen. Und ich habe es auch selten erlebt, in Kaiserslautern. Eigentlich meistens ist es in Kaiserslautern ein Vorteil, wenn du schon mal Spieler warst und den Verein kennst als Spieler. Aber irgendwie hat das auch Dimitrios Kramotsis nicht geholfen. Er hatte von Anfang an kein Standing und er hat es leider von Spiel zu Spiel schlimmer gemacht. Fragwürdige Entscheidungen auf dem Platz waren das eine, wirklich eine rätselhafte Kommunikation abseits des Platzes war. Das andere, ich weiß noch, das absolute Highlight oder eigentlich der Tiefpunkt, war das erste Spiel nach der Winterpause auf St. Pauli, 2-0 verloren. Und Kramotsis hat nach Spielende gesagt, ja, sie wollten dann das Torverhältnis halten. Und er meinte eigentlich nur die letzten zwei, drei Minuten. Doch er hatte in diesem Interview den Eindruck erweckt, dass sie nach dem 0-2 in der, ich glaube 65. Minute, dann das Torverhältnis halten wollten. Das hat ihm in Kaiserslautern so viel Kredit gekostet, gerade bei so einem Verein wie dem FCK, wo dieser Kampf, dieser Wille, Spiele zu drehen bis zur letzten Sekunde so tief in der Vereins-DNA verankert ist, wie vielleicht kaum woanders. Das hat ihm da irgendwie schon das Knick gebrochen. Und dann die sportliche Bilanz von sechs Ligaspielen, wo man nur fünf verloren hat. Und da hat ihn dann auch der Einzug ins Pokal-Halbfinale nicht gerettet.
Da muss ich tatsächlich einmal darauf zurückkommen, weil Kramozis, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hat im Pokal ja mehr Siege geholt als in der Liga. Er hat gegen Hertha und gegen Nürnberg gewonnen. Und das wird nicht eben interessant, weil das sind zwei Ligakonkurrenten. Also das sind zwei Vereine, nicht irgendwie, wo man sagt, okay, das ist dritte Liga oder das ist Bundesliga, wo die Voraussetzung einfach anders ist. Ich sage jetzt nicht den Satz fürs Phrasenschwein, aber wo alles einfach von der Voraussetzung bis hin an das Jahr auch trotzdem ist halt ein Du-or-Di-Spiel. Da kannst du dich halt am Ende nicht mit einem 2-2 oder so begnügen. Aber das fand ich schon wirklich kurios, wie er in solchen Spielen ja ganz anders reagiert hat. Und dann gab es ja dieses 4-1 gegen Schalke, das war der einzige Liga-Sieg. Gut, da kann man jetzt diskutieren, ob das mehr mit Kaiserslautern oder mal mit Schalke zu tun hatte. Aber was ich da – also du hast fragwürdige Entscheidungen angesprochen – was ich da so krass fand, da hat er ja auch diesen Dreierwechsel vorgenommen, den er jetzt in seinem letzten Spiel ja auch gemacht hat, wofür er auch so kritisiert war. Und das hat er wirklich so für mich von außen Grundzügen nach Verzweiflungstat, nach dem Motto, aber das hat ja in dem einzigen Spiel funktioniert, was ich sonst in der Liga gewonnen habe.
Es waren ganz wilde Personalentscheidungen dabei. Ich kann die Spiele gar nicht alle aufzählen, weil ich jetzt nochmal nachschlagen müsste, aber es gab mehrere Spieler, die bei Cramozis von der Startelf die Woche danach auf die Tribüne rotiert sind. Also es lag irgendwie kein – man hat kein Konzept erkannt. Das Ganze wurde noch dadurch völlig wild, dass der Thomas Hengen, der Geschäftsführer, vor der Installierung von Dimitrios Cramozis gesagt hat, egal wer der neue Trainer wird, wir wollen eine Dreierkette, also eine Dreierkette gegen den Ball bzw. Fünferkette gegen den Ball, Dreierkette mit dem Ball spielen, weil darauf wäre auch der Kader ausgerichtet. Dann trainiert Dimitrios Cramozis das gesamte Trainingslager im Winter, auch dieses Dreier-Fünferketten-System, um dann im ersten Spiel gegen St. Pauli eine Viererkette aufzubieten. Und jeder dachte sich so, what the fuck, was ist hier eigentlich los? Und diese spielerischen, du hast diese Wechsel, diese Dreifachwechsel angesprochen, diese Wechsel von der Stadion auf die Tribüne, diese taktischen Fragen. Er hat wirklich von Woche zu Woche selbst auch an seinem Trainerstuhl gesägt.
Aber du hast Thomas Hengen gerade schon angesprochen. So ganz kann man dann ja solche Positionen nicht rausrechnen. Also man guckt ja immer eigentlich auf den Sportdirektor oder Geschäftsführersport oder wie immer an den verschiedenen Standorten auch heißt. Weil bei drei Trainern in einer Saison ist das ja natürlich relativ klar. Ich fand bei Hengen es einfach ja nach außen hin, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es unprofessionell oder einfach nicht förderlich fand, dass er dann auch immer so ein bisschen wie so ein bockiges Kind gesagt hat, so ne, es gibt keine schlechte Stimmung im Kader, Gramozis wird respektiert. Das hört auf, hier irgendwie die Stimmung vergiften zu wollen. Und dann war zwei Wochen später Gramozis doch weg, gefühlt. Wie schaust du darauf Hengen?
Ja, wir müssen bei der Personalie Thomas Hengen noch eine zweite Person mit reinnehmen. Und das ist der Enes Hayri. Ich fange mal vorne an. Der Thomas Hengen ist ja 2021 gekommen. Dann ist der FCK gerade so nicht abgestiegen in die Regionalliga, ist ein Jahr darauf aufgestiegen und dann im ersten Jahr ja sehr gut in der zweiten Liga angekommen. Und in diesen Jahren war Thomas Hengen allein verantwortlich für den sportlichen Bereich. Und ich sage immer, individuell gute Einzelspiele, die findet jeder Sportdirektor, die findet auch jeder Scout, weil das ist einfach die Aufgabe in diesem Bereich. Aber du brauchst als Manager einfach dieses Händchen, um so einen Kader zu entwickeln, so eine Team-Chemie. Du musst gucken, dass dir Hierarchie passt. Und da kannst du ja nicht nur auf die individuellen Spielerwerte schauen. Und da hatte Thomas Hengen ein sehr, sehr gutes Händchen. Problem ist, es war einfach alles viel zu viel für ihn, weil alleiniger Geschäftsführer für den sportlichen, für den kaufmännischen Bereich, der Kerl war chronisch überarbeitet und er musste entlastet werden. Ja, das haben sie aber blöderweise, zumindest meiner Meinung nach, an der falschen Stelle gemacht. Sie haben ihn nämlich im sportlichen Bereich entlastet. Sie haben Enes Hayri, ehemaliger Spieler auch des FC Krasbiet-Spielspieler, hat er nicht gemacht, geholt und haben ihn offiziell technischen Direktor genannt. Diese verklausulierte Bezeichnung hat ihm natürlich sehr geholfen, unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit schwimmen zu können, weil technischer Direktor gibt es in vielen Vereinen und im Endeffekt weiß eigentlich niemand so recht, was die machen. In Wahrheit ist der Enes Hayri aber einfach Sportdirektor. Der Thomas Hengen hat jetzt schon in der vergangenen Sommer-Transferperiode den Großteil der Verhandlungen mit Spielern, mit potenziellen Neuzugängen an den Enes Hayri abgegeben. Und seitdem läuft es irgendwie nicht mal so rund. Der Enes Hayri hat auch eine enorm emotionale Art und ist dadurch bei diversen Leuten angeeckt. Mit Kierke Schuster kommt er überhaupt nicht mehr. Sicherlich war diese Verbindung Schuster-Hayri auch einer der Gründe, warum Schuster gehen musste. Aber auch diverse Mitarbeiter im Verein und auch zahlreiche Spieler, bei denen hat Hayri einfach seine Akzeptanz verloren. Und jetzt hat er im Winter sechs neue Spieler geholt. Und dadurch auch diese Team-Hierarchie, die eh schon seit dem Sommer so ein bisschen angeknackst war, jetzt wirklich vollends zerschlagen. Du hattest wichtige Spieler wie Terence, also wichtige Spieler für die Kabinen-Hierarchie, Stützen der Kabine mit Andreas Luthe, auch wenn er nicht mehr gespielt hat. Er ist wieder nach Bochum gegangen. Terence Boyd ist zu Waldhof Mannheim gegangen. Und es ist nicht so, dass er auf Teufel komm rausgehen wollte. Wenn du dem die sportliche Perspektive geboten hättest, dann wäre der auch geblieben. Du hast aber stattdessen andere Stürme, sogar drei an der Zahl geholt. Die für mich persönlich keinen Upgrade zu Boyd darstellen. Und auch Dimitris Kramotz, das wollte eigentlich gar nicht so viele Stürme. Der wollte eigentlich lieber einen schnellen Innenverteidiger, aber für den war dann kein Geld mehr da. Deswegen mit der Personalhaire hängt vieles zusammen, was beim FCK seit dem vergangenen Sommer schiefgegangen ist. Um jetzt aber nochmal auf Thomas Hengen zurückzukommen, das befreit Thomas Hengen natürlich nicht von seiner schlechten Trainer-Auswahl. Kramotzis war einfach ein totaler Fehler von Anfang an. Aber sehen wir es mal positiv. Er hat es immerhin jetzt erkannt und hat reagiert. Und hat vermutlich noch rechtzeitig reagiert.
Dann lass doch einmal kurz auf die Personaie Friedhelm Funkel gucken. War das für dich dann, also ein Trainer von dem Kaliber von Friedhelm Funkel, war das für dich dann jetzt genau der richtige Weg? Also weil es schreit ja schon alles sehr nach Feuerwehrmann.
Ja, ich glaube, es war völlig alternativlos, jetzt einen Feuerwehrmann zu holen. Du hast es zwei, also klar, dir geschust, da hattest du eher als Perspektiv-Trainer ja eigentlich gehabt. Und hast dann mit Kramotzis ja auch nochmal jemanden geholt, der das große und ganze auch längerfristig betreuen soll. Und nachdem zwei Trainer an dieser Mannschaft gescheitert sind, war jetzt klar, du musst jetzt einen erfahrenen Mann holen, der einfach nur bis zum Sommer – es ist auch klar kommuniziert – Friedhelm Funkel wird seine Rente mit inzwischen 70 Jahren nicht über die Saison hinaus verlängern. Und ja, nee, war alternativlos und aus meiner Perspektive oder meiner Meinung nach auch die absolut richtige Entscheidung. Anna hat der Freund im Zuge von Benjamin Kessel gesagt, dass dadurch, dass du mit Benjamin Kessel in Braunschweig diese Identifikationsfigur hast, brauchst du sie nicht zwangsläufig auf dem Trainerposten. Und in Kaiserslautern hast du halt diese Identifikationsfigur nicht so richtig auf einem anderen Posten. Auch wenn Thomas Hengen früher mal Spieler war in Kaiserslautern, der ist jetzt nicht so ein nahbarer oder zumindest nach außen hin so emotionaler Typ, wo du sagst, Herr Geheim, Thomas Hengen. Aber Friedhelm Funkel ist es eben. Und ich war am vergangenen Mittwoch bei seiner Vorstellung in Kaiserslautern und der Parkplatz zwischen Stadion und Trainingsplatz, das ist allen hätten geplatzt. Das waren in der Spitze an einem Mittwochnachmittag bei Nieselregen über 1000 Leute bei diesem Training.
Ja, also ich würde dann tatsächlich aber nachhaken wollen, weil ja, das ist jetzt eine Idee bis zum Sommer, aber du stehst ja im Sommer wieder vor der gleichen Problematik. Also du hast am Anfang gesagt, du gehst nicht davon aus, dass der FCK absteigen wird, eben auch wegen Friedhelm Funkel. Aber wenn wir dann jetzt mal auf den Sommer gucken, dann machen ja im Zweifel die gleichen Entscheider, sind wieder dafür verantwortlich, einen neuen Trainer zu finden. Hast du da so ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass sich bis dahin dann auch da nochmal was tut, dass es vielleicht auch nochmal da personelle Änderungen gibt? Und wer wäre für dich vielleicht da auch so der Kandidat, wo du sagst, okay, das könnte dann passen?
Also an Thomas Hengen, an der Personalie Thomas Hengen, wird sofern der Klassenerhalt geschafft wird, wird da nichts passieren. Ich bin aber sehr gespannt, wie es mit Enita Iri weitergeht. Nachdem wir diese Personalie in unserer Berichterstattung in den letzten Wochen auch sehr, sehr häufig thematisiert haben, ist jetzt auch die aktive Fanszene darauf angesprungen. Hat jetzt bei dem Spiel in Nürnberg auch ein Plakat hochgehalten nach dem Motto technischen Direktor hinterfragen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob er über den Sommer hinaus noch in Kaiserslautern ist. Ich glaube, es wäre gut für den Verein, wenn Thomas Hengen wieder mehr Verantwortung und mehr in den Mittelpunkt des sportlichen Geschehens rückt. Als die Trainersuche angeht, glaube ich, dass diese Situation mit dem Vertrag, also die Vertragssituation Funkel bis Saisonende kann eine große Chance sein für den FCK. Weil eigentlich, du wirst es vielleicht auch spielefeld kennen, in Kaiserslautern ist es Tradition, dass eigentlich ein Trainer beim Saisonende schon so ein bisschen angeschossen ist. Aber du gehst halt trotzdem mit ihm in die nächste Saison rein. Und meistens ist es dann im Oktober oder November dann halt so weit und er wird entlassen. Es gab in Kaiserslautern in den letzten 15 Jahren tatsächlich nur zwei Trainer, die zu Beginn einer neuen Saison neu eingestiegen sind. Und deswegen sehe ich das positiv und sehe das als Chance, dass du was neu aufbauen kannst, dass du ja unvorbelastet reingehen kannst. Aber nichtsdestotrotz steht und fällt dann alles mit der Personalie. In Köln hat ja Friedhelm Funkel, also Friedhelm Funkel hatte Köln vor, ich glaube, was? 2021, wo er sie gerettet hat. Genau, 2021. Und da war es ja genau das Gleiche. Und wer ist auf Friedhelm Funkel gefolgt? Steffen Baumgart. Und ich glaube auch, dass Steffen Baumgart eine sehr passende und vor allem auch wegen seiner Emotionen sehr passender Trainer für den FCK gewesen wäre. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass er das gemacht hätte. Nur ist er jetzt halt aus FCK-Sicht, dummerweise seit wenigen Stunden vom Markt. Deswegen, ich will gar keine Namen nennen, weil ich auch nicht weiß, worauf es dann hinauslaufen könnte. Aber ich sehe das als Chance für den Verein.
Jonas, wie schaust du darauf, dass auch ein Verein wie der FCK da durchaus seine Probleme mitbringt?
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe zwei Brüder. Einer ist Schalke-Fan, der andere ist Dauerkarten-Hinhaber in Kaiserslautern. Das heißt, ich habe bisher schon sehr viel Leid geklagt bekommen in dieser Saison. Das Problem, das ich in Kaiserslautern tatsächlich auch sehe, ist der Druck auf dem Kessel. Der wird nicht kleiner, weil Thomas Heng hat es schon mal gesagt. Um Kaiserslautern wirtschaftlich wieder zu sanieren, muss man eigentlich in die erste Liga. Man braucht diese TV-Gelder aus der ersten Liga, weil das in der zweiten Liga nicht ausreicht. Man hat zwar diese Corona-Insolvenz gehabt, aber ich sehe da noch einen sehr, sehr weiten Weg. Und wie der Moritz das schon richtig gesagt hat, also es ist völlig offen, was im Sommer passiert. Ab und zu geistert immer wieder der Name Stefan Kunz durch die Gegend, was auch wieder so eine Identifikationsfigur in Kaiserslautern wäre. Aber wie gesagt, das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen, was da passiert, eben weil auch so viele Emotionen an diesem Verein dranhängen. Aber ich sehe es auf jeden Fall noch einen ziemlich langen Weg, bis in Kaiserslautern der Druck des Erfolgs mal ein bisschen abnimmt, bevor man wieder wirklich in Fahrwasser kommt, wo man wirklich locker planen kann quasi. Also bevor da wirklich wieder mal ein bisschen Druckabbau da ist. Und ich glaube, man hat es auch gemerkt an der Entscheidung, die man mit der man Antwerpen damals entlassen hat und Schuster eingesetzt hat. Also der Druck ist extrem hoch in Kaiserslautern, irgendwie zum Erfolg zu kommen, um diesen Verein am Leben zu erhalten. Und ich glaube, der wird auch in den nächsten Jahren mit kleiner.
Bei Marco Antwerpen finde ich ja sehr interessant, dass er jetzt Trainer bei Waldorf-Mannchen ist.
Zusammen mit Terence Boyd.
Das ist einfach eine sehr schöne Connection. Anna, wie ist das bei dir? Wie schaust du auf den FCK? Ja, wie überrascht bist du vielleicht auch ein bisschen, dass die da so weit runter eingerutscht sind?
Nicht so sehr, muss ich sagen, weil es irgendwie ein sportliches Niveau ist, auf dem ich das Team eher verortet hätte als eins, das ja mit uns zusammen aufgestiegen ist aus der 3. Liga. Und das ist noch nicht so lange her. Und ich finde, dass die Vereine einerseits so mit ganz anderen Themen zu kämpfen haben, aber glaube ich, ich meine, das kennst du ja aus vielem Feld ja auch, dieses Lied dieses, da geht es wirklich, wirklich um den langfristigen Erhalt des Vereins. Wenn wir darüber reden, Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga oder nicht, weil die 3. Liga langfristig die 4. Liga bedeutet. Also das sind keine Vereine, die sich etablieren werden in Liga 3, dafür sind sie zu groß. Also zumindest ist mir da bisher kein wirtschaftliches Konzept plausibel gemacht worden, was da diese Schrumpfungen gesund hinbekommen würde. Und ich glaube, das verbindet Eintracht Braunschweig mit dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die ja noch viel erfolgreicher in der Historie gewesen sind im Vergleich zu uns. Aber dieses, wenn wir absteigen, dann geht es halt wieder einfach um alles. Und deswegen, weiß ich nicht, Moritz, ob du mir dazu stimmen würdest, aber empfinde ich den Kampf um den Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga immer auch als existenziell, auch wenn es so ein bisschen, man nimmt es mit Geigenhumor, man versucht da irgendwie, ja, den Mut nicht zu verlieren oder den Kopf nicht in den Sand zu stecken oder welche Reden zwar dann auch immer angemessen sein könnte, aber am Ende des Tages ist es halt wirklich kein Spaß. Also ich fand das vorhin ganz schön, Jonas, wie du gesagt hast, ich dachte, das ist hier irgendwie totale Stahlraffenland und ich habe immer nur Angst. Liga ist wirklich, ich will jetzt auch gar nicht in deinen Wunden rühren, Eva, aber es ist nicht so schlimm. Und ich glaube, das geht den Leuten in Kaiserslautern genauso.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist eben auch ein ganz großes Problem von Erwartungshaltung. Also was für einen negativen Kredit vielleicht einfach Traditionsvereine mit sich bringen. Also ja, SV Elversberg sieht sich vielleicht langfristig 2. 3. Liga und Kaiserslautern sagt, wir brauchen die Bundesliga eigentlich. Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, der Bielefeld ist nicht geschafft, zumindest ein Jahr in der Bundesliga zu sein. Es wird noch schlechter aussehen, aber man hat eben das Geld auch damals viel zu schnell verprasst, was dadurch entstanden ist und weil es Corona war etc. Ich meine, dass Vereine sowieso viel zu schlecht aufgestellt sind. Ich meine, da brauchen wir uns nur die komplette Situation gerade anzugucken. Aber ich finde es eben doch so interessant, wie viel dann eben auch gerade, wenn es um Trainerentscheidungen geht, wie viel da dann getrieben wird und wie viel man dann sagt, okay, wir stecken jetzt doch spontan Geld da und da rein und machen so. Es sind eigentlich Panikkäufe. Also, alles schreit irgendwie nach Full-Panic-Mode. Und wir müssen da irgendwie möglichst schnell rauskommen. Und wir denken zwar nicht von Spiel zu Spiel, aber wir denken gerade mal von Halbserie zu Halbserie. Und das ist, glaube ich, so was, was einen Kaiserslautern ein, einen Braunschweig vielleicht auch ein, einen Bielefeld ein. Ja, wahrscheinlich auch momentan, wenn wir auf Schalke 04 gucken, etc. Das ist alles was, und was vielleicht dann bei einem VfL Osnabrück, auch wie in Wiesbaden, SV Elversberg, vielleicht nicht so der Druck ist, dass man sagt so, ja, okay, bei uns war jetzt in der Finanzplanung nicht komplett eingerechnet, dass wir jetzt fünf Jahre 2. Liga spielen so und mit Aussicht auf Bundesliga. Und ich glaube, es ist ein riesengroßes Problem. Und ja, da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt, wie Kaiserslautern das jetzt auch löst.
Wer den FCK in der 3. Liga gesehen hat, gerade in den Jahren, wo es dort sportlich nicht lief, es war ja so trostlos, dieses tolle Stadion. Und dann sind da 16, 17.000 Zuschauer und das ist irgendwie. Und wer diesen Verein jetzt wieder sieht, mit einem Zuschauerschnitt von über 40.000 Leuten. Und diese Erwartungshaltung, ja, die ist immer groß in Kaiserslautern, aber die ist jetzt nicht so, dass es heißt, wir müssen unbedingt aufsteigen. Ich glaube, viele im Umfeld des FCKs finden es aktuell so rein von der Konstellation, welche Mannschaften in der 2. Liga spielen oder hin besser in der 2. Liga zu spielen. Und wenn du dort eine erfolgreiche Saison – und erfolgreich sage ich jetzt mal, du landest am Ende vielleicht auf einem 7. Platz oder auf einem 6. Platz – wenn du sowas mal wieder spielst, dann macht es den meisten vermutlich sogar viel mehr Spaß, als wenn du in der Bundesliga spielst, wo du realistisch gesehen völlig auf die Ohren kriegst und dich vielleicht mit Ach und Krach irgendwie auf den 15. oder 14. Platz oder so retten kannst. Und um Anna nochmal aufzugreifen, falls es tatsächlich dieses Jahr doch am Ende runtergehen sollte in die 3. Liga, wird es finanziell auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr düster aussehen. So allein jetzt in der 2. Liga ist das jährliche Defizit im Bereich von 5 bis 7 Millionen Euro, das durch Investoren ausgeglichen wird. Jonas hat im Grunde recht, eigentlich trägt sich das Ganze nur in der Bundesliga. Es würde sich vermutlich auch in der 2. Liga tragen, wenn du halt in der Fernsegel-Tabelle der 2. Liga relativ nach oben springen würdest. Aber das ist halt ein Prozess, der 5, 6, 7 Jahre dauert, bis du irgendwie 18 Mannschaften oder zumindest 14, 15 Mannschaften im TV-Wanking überholt hast.
Ja, lass uns einfach ganz kurz auf die nächsten Spiele des FCK schauen. Auch da zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe, dann auch auswärts bei Rostock und zu Hause gegen Osnabrück. Also gerade Rostock und Osnabrück sind wahrscheinlich auch wieder diese, okay, die muss man gewinnen. Also da reicht kein Punkt, da hilft ein Punkt einfach überhaupt nicht weiter, gerade wenn man schaut, wie eng es da unten drin auch ist.
Du hast, du hast vorhin was Gutes angesprochen und du hast dich so ein bisschen gewundert über die Pokalspiele unter Kramozis. Es ist ja so eine chronische FCK-Krankheit seit vielen, vielen Jahren, dass in den besonderen Spielen, seit es Pokalspiele oder seit es Ligaspiele wie jetzt gegen Schalke, gegen Hamburg, gegen Hertha, das sind den Spielen, diese Mannschaft ganz anders auftritt als in Spielen gegen die vermeintlich kleine. Jonas wird es wissen, der FCK hat gerade in Elversberg verloren. Und das ist ja einfach, das ist ja eine Frage des Mindsets und der Einstellung. Und da ist jetzt halt Friedhelm Funkel gefragt. Und ich glaube einfach, dass er mit seiner Erfahrung von über 800 Spielen als Trainer in der ersten und zweiten Liga einfach weiß, wo er da ansetzen muss. Weil klar, du musst auch die Defensive in den Griff kriegen, der FCK hat mit 43 Gegentoren die zweitmeisten der Liga kassiert. Aber viel wichtig ist, ist es einfach in die Köpfe der Spieler reinzukommen und denen klar zu machen, dass es jetzt auch gegen Osnabrück, gegen den Letzten, dass du da nicht überheblich rangehst und denkst, ja wir sind ja der große FCK und wir gehören da unten ja eigentlich nicht hin, sondern wir gehören ja eigentlich viel weiter oben hin. Weil das ist eine wahnsinnig gefährliche Einstellung. Weil der FCK ist nie abgestiegen, egal ob aus der Bundesliga, der zweiten Liga, ist nie abgestiegen, weil er super schlecht war, sondern weil er nie, weil er nichts aus seinen Möglichkeiten gemacht hat. Und so ähnlich ist es dieses Jahr auch wieder. Und das Derby gegen KSC nächste Woche wird jetzt halt auch für die Stimmung im Umfeld enorm wichtig. Das erste Heimspiel von Friedhelm Funkel gegen Karlsruhe. Wenn er das gewinnt, dann könnte das schon wieder so eine Initialzündung sein, die den Verein und die Mannschaft einfach durch die nächsten Wochen trägt.
Ja und man ist ja eben noch im DFB-Pokal dabei. Also lass dir jetzt mal den Run aufbauen und dann lass dich noch im DFB-Pokal weiterkommen und hinterher vielleicht sogar im Finale stehen. So ist natürlich immer irgendwas zwischen Chance und ja auch immer so ein bisschen natürlich auch Risiko. Hinterher verlierst du das Halbfinale, last minute, das verletzt dich noch irgendwer und dann stehst du natürlich doch wieder mit nichts da. Ich finde es einfach eine sehr interessante Geschichte, die auch der FCK jetzt diese Saison oder die letzten zwei Jahre genommen hat.
Ich finde es gerade in dem Zusammenhang, dass jetzt unter Umständen Saarbrücken, wenn sie gegen Gladbach gewinnen oder halt der FCK die Chance hat, ins Finale einzuziehen. Unter diesen Umständen finde ich es einfach so schade, dass es die Regel nicht mal gibt, dass der Pokalverlierer den Europapokal Platz bekommt. Dann hätte diese ganze Pokalsaison doch nochmal einen ganz anderen Charme oder auch selbst für Mönchengladbach, die halt irgendwie ihre Saison damit nochmal retten könnten. Weil gehen wir realistisch ran, selbst wenn der FCK 1 Finale kommt und dort auf Bayer Leverkusen trifft, dann ist der FCK der Verein der Bayer Leverkusen die erste Saison niederleitet.
Ich bin da auch ganz ehrlich, also nach den letzten zwei Pokalsiegern wäre es uns auch verdient, sowas wieder einzuführen. Aber es ist nur meine persönliche Meinung. Generell muss ich echt wieder sagen, diese Liga schafft es immer wieder, mich dermaßen zu überraschen. Ich wäre gerne weiterhin Teil von ihr. Ich bin immer ein bisschen neidisch auf euch, trotz allem, trotz Existenz, Hans. Ich mag es einfach, dass es eben doch so ist, dass auch für Aussteiger die Chance ein bisschen mehr da ist, sich irgendwie zumindest für ein Jahr oder für zwei Jahre mal zu etablieren und da irgendwie ein bisschen Luft zu schnappen. Das finde ich schon irgendwie ein bisschen angenehmer und ich hatte ganz am Anfang angesprochen, letztes Wochenende war die Bundesliga, hatte glaube ich einmal das Eintrachtstadion mehr an Zuschauerinnen als die Bundesliga. Klar, kann man natürlich auch diskutieren, woran das liegt, aber ich finde es trotzdem irgendwie auch stark, dass trotzdem so viele Leute zu Schalke gehen, zu Kaiserslautern gehen, zu Braunschweig gehen und Co. obwohl vielleicht nicht immer alles glatt läuft, obwohl vielleicht nicht alles passt und ich finde das einfach ein sehr, sehr schönes Zeichen für, ja, was fanlieber eigentlich auch ist.
Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass dieser Rekord noch nicht mal unter, ich nenne es jetzt mal, optimalsten Bedingungen aufgestellt worden ist, weil der FCK hatte ja zum Beispiel gar kein Heimspiel und in Kaiserslautern wären roundabout nochmal 10.000 Leute mehr gewesen als jetzt bei dem Spiel in Nürnberg.
Ja, also wir hatten vorhin, ich glaube, auch 8.000 Leute bei Elversberg, bis hin zu 60.000 Leute bei Schalke gegen Wiesbaden, wirklich alles dabei. Und das ist schon, also, ja, um da natürlich auch nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, das ist eben auch doch das Herz und die Seele des deutschen Fußballs. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr schön. Möchtet ihr noch irgendwas zu den drei Vereinen sagen? Trinken noch was los während zur Lage der Liga? Ja, Kinder.
Ich glaube, es wäre für den FCK besser, das Halbfinale zu Hause gegen Gladbach zu spielen als in Saarbrücken. Klingt jetzt vielleicht im ersten Moment komisch, weil du hättest einen Erstligisten oder einen Drittligisten zur Wahl. Aber in Saarbrücken wäre so ziemlich das unangenehmste Spiel, was den FCK treffen könnte, obwohl er eigentlich in den Drittliga-Jahren eine sehr gute Derby-Bilanz hatte gegen Saarbrücken und kein Spiel verloren hat. Aber so oder so sage ich natürlich, der FCK kommt ins Finale, aber realistisch gesehen muss er sich dort einfach auf einen schönen Tag freuen und alles andere ausblenden.
Allein schon wegen dem Rasen wäre es wahrscheinlich besser in Kaiserslautern.
Aber der wird ja gerade ausgetauscht.
Eventuell ist er bis Sonntag aber nicht fertig. Und mein Verein spielt ja am Sonntag. Wir wissen noch nicht, ob wir vielleicht nach Frankfurt müssen stattdessen. Ist auch quasi die gleiche Strecke von mir.
Schwimmwesten mitnehmen.
Ja, gut. Sind wir ehrlich, das hat auch keinen großen Einfluss auf den Fußball, der hier gespielt wird. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Aber nochmal, um auf Annas Frage zurückzukommen, es wäre ja eigentlich kein gutes Oben, wenn der FCK den Pokal wirklich gewinnen sollte, weil Abstiege und Pokalsiege in einem Jahr, damit kennt sich der FCK ja ganz gut aus.
Ja, und so schön, als Oben-Liga-Pokalsieger da dann nach Europa zu fahren.
Ich glaube sogar, durch die Einnahmen, die du dann durch die europäischen Spiele kriegst, könntest du auch wirtschaftlich den 1-Jahr-3. Liga wieder ganz gut abfedern. Aber ich glaube, das will keiner.
Es ist tatsächlich ein Verein dabei, wo man wenig Vorstellungen hat, wer die momentan schlagen soll. Aber wenigstens auch mit sehr schönem Fußball. Ich finde, das ist ja, womit ich dann klarkommen kann, tatsächlich als neutrale Beobachterin. Gut, ich fand es ein sehr schönes, vielleicht auch kitschiges Fußball-Pledoyer zum Ende und möchte als allererstes kurz noch ein paar Service-Mitteilungen hier in die Runde laufen. Heute ist ein Schwerpunkt zur SGE mit Stefan Reich und Max erschienen. Am Ende der Woche erwartet euch dann noch eine weitere Ligatur zu den europäischen Ligen und der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt weiterhin werbe- paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Unterstützt bitte den Rasenfunk, um die Arbeit, die Max hier wirklich wöchentlich leistet, auch ein bisschen zurückzuzahlen, wenn ihr könnt. Und bevor ich euch hier gleich bedanke, meinen Gästinnen, möchte ich kurz auf einer neueren Person hinter den Kulissen danken und ein paar Worte widmen vielen Dank an Moritz für die Hilfe bei der Organisation dieser Folge. Das macht wirklich sehr, sehr vieles entspannter, zumindest für mich, sodass ich dann auch am Wochenende in Ruhe in den Stadion gehen kann und weiß, dass das ist irgendwie alles geregelt. Das ist eine sehr, sehr wertvolle Unterstützung. Danke an der Stelle. Und dann möchte ich natürlich auf diese Runde danken. Vielen lieben Dank an Anna. Schön, dass du dabei warst. Schön, dass du uns alles über Braunschweig erzählt hast. Danke, dass du da warst. Ja, lieben Dank auch an Jonas. Es war ein Debüt, als würdest du nichts anderes tun. Ich glaube, alle haben so ein bisschen mal die SV Elversberg jetzt kennengelernt. Sehr schön, dass du auch da mit am Start warst.
Vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein durfte.
Und zum Schluss auch Danke an Moritz Kreilinger. Danke für dein Know-how zum FCK und für den Hottag direkt zu Beginn. Vielen Dank.
Es war mir eine Freude mit euch. Und ich freue mich auf die Spezialfolge zum DFB Pokalfinale.
Gott, Max wird mich umbringen. Dann, wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche euch noch eine schöne Restwoche. Und habt ein schönes Wochenende auch schon mal.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.